[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine
bayerische torte wir machen die
prinzregenten torte jetzt würde mich mal
interessieren wer von euch kennt die
prinzregenten torte schreibt mir jetzt
unten in die kommentare
ich kenne sie schon aber ich muss auch
sagen ich bin ja in einem café groß
geworden da gab es auch immer selbst
gebackene torten und kuchen von meiner
mutter und die prinzregenten torte habe
ich in umfragen sticker bei instagram
von euch halt gesehen erinnert hell
macht jedoch mal und da habe ich mir
gedacht fangen wir direkt mal an ich
zeige euch erstmal das rezept für meinen
schokopudding dem müssen auskühlen
lassen und dann geht erst mal mit dem
boden weiter ich schreibe euch wie immer
alle ganz genauen mengenangaben unten
infobox und richtig los und geht erst
mal alle zutaten für den pudding in
meinem kopf
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt noch speisestärke zucker
und zartbitter kuvertüre dazu gegeben
mein herz ist übrigens ausgeschaltet
dann ist es wichtig wie verrühren das
ganze so lange bis ihr merkt dass die
speisestärke auch richtig gut in der
milch aufgelöst wurde und sich damit
verbunden hat und erst jetzt den herd
einschalten für mich funktioniert diese
methode im am besten wenn ihr einen topf
oder eine pfanne verwendet die halt so
vom durchmesser auch ein bisschen größer
ist und jetzt die ganze zeit umrühren
kapoor stufe acht von neun und werde es
dann so lange umrühren bis es irgendwann
auf kocht und ein bisschen dicker wird
[Musik]
den pudding dann einfach oben
frischhaltefolie direkt auf die
oberfläche geben und vollständig
auskühlen lassen wir müssen jetzt aber
die zwischenzeit und machen schon mal
den boden ich nehme eine küchenmaschine
natürlich durfte auch ein handrührgerät
benutzen wie bei allen meinen rezepten
da ich bekomme immer noch auf die frage
ob das denn geht auf jeden fall dauert
wirklich nur 23 minuten länger es geht
jetzt hier zimmer warme butter in die
schüssel da gebe ich zucker mit dazu und
vanille extrakt und dann wird das ganze
45 minuten lang richtig schön hague
cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
nachdem wir dann die eier nach und nach
eingerührt haben also wirklich jedes 120
sekunden einreden lassen sind wir auch
schon soweit und können die trockenen
zutaten dazugeben dafür einfach
nacheinander mehlspeise stärke und
backpulver hinzusehen und wenn ihr dann
wirklich nur 20 sekunden rührt ist der
teig auch schon fertig also wirklich
nicht zu führen ich will jetzt meine
backbleche meine tortenring und dann
werden alle böden wirklich einzelnen
gebieten also ich muss ehrlich zugeben
jetzt die böden zu backen ist so das
mühselig sahnetorte aber es lohnt sich
jetzt hier mein backblech ich nehme mir
das gelochte das ist nämlich richtig
schön glatt und dadurch dass die bürger
extrem dünn werden ist halt wirklich von
vorteil denn dann backen sie wirklich
gleichmäßig durch und haben hat nicht
diesen typischen hobel den mann von den
normalen backbleche kennt und darauf
gebe ich jetzt meinen touren bringen
habe ich hier auf 26 cm eingestellt ich
jetzt einfach umbauen müsste nicht
einschlagen und jetzt werden die böden
ganz dünn darauf verstrichen ich
persönlich arbeite immer parallel wenn
das ganze noch einmal darf dann macht es
halt immer nacheinander und jetzt gebe
ich euch noch einen richtig guten tipp
damit die böden auch wirklich
gleichmäßig werden und nochmal später im
anschnitt dass wir so übermäßig oft ihr
gemeldet aber eure küchenwaage macht man
eure richtung und eigentlich schlau
gewesen aber ich hab's vergessen die
schüssel vorher abzuwägen ich habe zum
glück immer nur zweite wahl und gibt dir
einfach oben drauf dann schaue ich mir
das gewicht an und ziehe die gleich ab
oder ich direkt auf null gibt dann die
andere schüssel natürlich ohne intakt
aber um drauf und dann habe ich nämlich
die gesamtmasse die teile ich dann durch
8 und weiß ganz genau wie viel gramm
einen boden wiegen muss das haben wir
hier also
866 jeder boden ist so ungefähr ein
bisschen mehr als 100 gramm ein bisschen
verlust hat man immer also ich mache mal
so 105 gramm ungefähr pro boden und dann
werde ich sie mit meiner streich palette
verstreichen und bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr acht bis elf
minuten backen bitte habt immer ein auge
drauf das wenig zu dunkel
[Musik]
beim verstreichen welt übrigens das
gefühl haben so hell
das soll reichen so wenig für einen
boden aber es ist tatsächlich so und
deshalb ist mir wichtig dass wir darauf
achtet dass zumindest außen dass ihr das
backpapier auch nicht durch seht im
besten falle geht es nur ums wodurch
dann ist es nämlich perfekt verstrichen
denn gerade außen kann es sein dass so
was mal schnell bricht und gleich wenn
der erste wurden gebacken dass ich mal
nacheinander gleichzeitig geht leider
nicht dann direkt mit dem bug formloser
lösen so lange sie noch warm sind denn
dann können die nämlich auch nicht
brechen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die böden ausgebacken
könnt ihr euch ruhig so eineinhalb
stunden zeit für einen teil aber dafür
geht der rest echt schnell denn
traditionell kommt er jetzt eine
buttercreme in die zwischenschichten und
ich weiß es viele von euch buttercreme
es nicht ganz so mögen sie aber oft
daran dass man sie einfach nicht lang
genug aufschlägt wenn ihr butter lange
genug aufstellt ich mache das täglich
acht bis zehn minuten in der
küchenmaschine dann wird die ganz anders
von der konsistenz und verändert sich
auch so ein bisschen im geschmack und
dominant ist ja auch noch unsere unter
schokopudding der dann nach den acht
minuten dann noch mit dazu kommt und ein
gerührt wird und das mache ich jetzt in
danach schichten wie die torte
[Musik]
die creme fertig das heißt wir fangen an
zu schichten ich mache es so ich hab
hier den ersten boden auf einem
kiteboard dann gebe ich jetzt einfach
meint ob im ring drumherum den habe ich
doch gar nicht sauber gemacht denn wir
verwerten ihn jetzt direkt weiter einmal
drumherum spannend und jetzt einfach
gleichmäßig die creme verteilen nachdem
geschichtet habt am besten noch mal für
eine halbe stunde kühlen und dann zeige
ich euch wie der bus funktioniert
[Musik]
ich würde sagen wir machen dann schon
mal den guss ich habe jetzt für zar
peter gust entschieden ich finde es dann
nicht ganz so süß und wenn ihr mögt
könnt ihr auch gerne vollmilch nehmen
erinnert sich an den mengenangaben
nichts gibt es noch den rest von unserer
mutter einmal in meine kleine panne und
da kommt ein bisschen sahne dazu und
fein gehackte peter kuvertüre und dann
ganz langsam erwärmen so dass ich alles
miteinander verbindet
[Musik]
also das war jetzt das beste
paradebeispiel dafür dass man einfach
geduldig bleiben muss ich hatte nämlich
die kühe zeit nicht ganz beachtet weil
wir drehen hier und da habe ich einfach
das ganze schon früher auf dem
kühlschrank genommen das war sehr
unstabil das heißt wenn ihr sie lange im
kühlschrank lässt dann klappt es auch
dass sie den bus richtig schön runter
drücken lassen könnt ich werde jetzt mit
der winkel palette einfach nachhelfen
ich finde es auch gar nicht schlimm habe
mein kate bot unten drunter und ich
mache jetzt so dass ich die ganze nacht
kühl nasse damit die böden durch das
kühlen durch die feuchtigkeit auch
richtig schön weich werden und am
nächsten tag rufe ich dann in den hansa
zu mir dann machen wir den test zusammen
[Musik]
nachdem die torte dann wurde durch
gekürt ist können wir sie verzieren ich
nehme dafür kalte schlagsahne und
schlagt sie zusammen mit vanille extrakt
etwas geliebten ba cacau und sami fest
komplett steif und spritze dann zwölf
richtig hübsche röschen auf die ich noch
mit pistazien dekorieren
[Musik]
ich habe mir den holen wir machen den
test als ich habe übrigens pistazien und
hopp gegeben wie findest du die optik an
sagt sehr schön es hat sich das über
lerne ist
schon das ist eigentlich nicht üblich
aber so modernen twist wollte ich den
ganzen der kontrast ist richtig schön
sieht ein bisschen aus wie somit dürfte
dies nicht auch so ein bisschen mit
doppelgänger weniger schichten oktobers
torte ist auch so ein ähnlich war also
von von der arbeit her selbst das obama
sagen dankeschön des sehr weich geworden
was super ist ganz schlicht man kommt
ganz vielleicht durch mit der gabe und
schmeckt echt wo es schmeckt wenig nicht
zu süßen babys noch mit kaffeeduft ich
weiß das sag ich immer aber ist von
kaffee dazu vor allem das wird richtig
gut passen würde ich schmecke heftig
also man glaubt das ist schon eher hart
aus aber man ist das so richtig weiß ja
das ist richtig so weißt doch wie so was
mich ist diese manamana
pixel dahin auch so aus quasi oder den
ball bei state index ist knackig also
ich bin richtig happy mit dem rezept
tempel weg sagt ein bisschen etwas
abgewandelt ist die moderne variante
hast du irgendwas zu sagen ist unsinn
sprachlos gerade ein großer tag das ist
für den boden wand einfach vanille böden
mit also ganz einer schanze das schmeckt
ein bisschen klicks boden ja weil die
einzeln gebacken werden das macht sie
besonders das ist ja auch der
aufwändigste part aber es lohnt sich es
gibt aber auch konditoreien die sind so
geübten machen ein boden und schneiden
den dann sieben mal fein durch so dass
sie acht böden erhalten wollte sich auch
sofort total gerade so wenn du einmal
ist alles so zum marktstart immer schön
aus dann würde ich mal sagen macht
unbedingt nach oben falls ihr fotos
wasser macht dann teilt das doch gerne
in euren stories bei instagram und
ansonsten bis zum nächsten mal
die haben wir nie einfach nein
[Musik]